18 is a little
sorry for anything today
the twilight saga was a worldwide
phenomenon and without its very first
film the franchise wouldn't have reached
the success it did
so what exactly made the first movie so
special
today we're giving you a
behind-the-scenes look at some of the
most
surprising and adorable moments that
happened on set
even the most hardcore twyhards will be
questioning
everything they know about the film glad
you're here we need an
empire she thinks we cheat i know you're
cheap
it's time to talk about how they brought
this thunderous baseball scene to life
putting together a vampire baseball
scene wasn't easy for anyone
the visual effects team had to map out
the entire scene digitally so that
they'd be able to add any extra footage
they needed
catherine hardwick said they originally
wanted a little bit of sunshine but soon
realized that would mean
making the cullen clan sparkle an effect
that would cost them
big bucks that was as far as the digital
effects went this twilight film was on a
budget which meant using as many
practical effects as possible
the most impressive part of the scene is
how they got the vampires moving for the
cullens
they were attached to ropes and
harnesses while running to help them
achieve a smoother glide
but for villains james laurent and
victoria their actors walked through the
field on a magical green carpet to make
it seem as if they were floating
you better hold on tight spider monkey
bella and edward's infamous treetop
scene took quite a few different shots
with plenty of rope stunt doubles and a
helicopter to
get this shot it was made possible but
there was still some tweaking that
needed to be done
like moving trees and adding in
cardboard ones to make the forest
look a little more full however the best
part of the behind the scenes may just
be how
adorable rob and kristen were with one
another
do you trust me in theory
the cgi and visual effects in twilight
were very minimal but there was no way
to have our paths attack a deer like
edward without the help of some movie
magic
this opening scene was completely
digital from the forest
deer running and edward snatching it up
mid-jump it was all done with computers
check out the breakdown of this scene
across the frame to tackle the deer and
of course we couldn't do that for real
so we did that in visual effects
talk about a jigsaw puzzle the car
accident seen in the parking lot of
forks high was filmed in multiple parts
this was to make sure they kept the cast
and crew
as safe as possible rob and kristen
filmed their parts without the car even
being there
the actual accident was filmed without
any actors nearby
as for edward's superhuman strength the
car door was made out of a soft metal
panel with plasticine backings that was
easy to mold
the complexity of the scene led to
plenty of adorable moments between the
actors on set that day
especially kristin this adorable behind
the scenes moment
shows off that props even large ones
don't always function properly
kristen couldn't get the door open to
the truck and ruined the entire take
on one hand the mishap allowed her to
show off her goofy side to us
hi i'm robert and i'm kristen
rob and kristen didn't spend all their
time on set sometimes they would get
called in for behind the scenes
interviews where things got
hilarious for actors these two really
couldn't seem to remember the lines for
the interview why do i
i keep thinking that is part of the
thing let's see oh this comes down to
some of these seven all right it made it
all
even more adorable their chemistry off
and on screen was undeniable
okay i'm sorry i can't look at you when
i do it alright bella swan
isn't the most coordinated person we
know that from the very moment she steps
in the gym on her first day of school
volleyball definitely isn't her forte
but it turns out it's also not kristin's
in these behind-the-scenes clips you can
see that the moment where bella
accidentally hits mike in the head with
the volleyball wasn't her
it was a crew member on set purposely
aiming the volleyball
at actor michael welch instead they
needed someone with good aim to
replicate bella's bad aim how ironic
you're good how meta was the moment
edward caught the apple and replicated
the twilight book cover
well it may have looked cool but robert
pattinson would probably tell you it was
just annoying to film
the moment took 13 takes in total they
attached the apple to a fishing line
and on a crane so that they'd be able to
give off the effect of edward bouncing
the apple back up with his foot and
landing in his hands perfectly
it's a good thing rob and kristen found
the whole thing hilarious between
takes edible art
the wolves don't exactly become a main
focus of the franchise until new moon
but catherine hardwick still wanted to
include them when talking about the
cullens and quillute's history
the most cost-friendly way to do this
was to bring in
actual wolves instead of using visual
effects it ended up turning out
extremely authentic
beautiful very visually dynamic
filming in a room full of mirrors a
filmmaker's
nightmare the studio fight between
edward and james was extremely difficult
to execute because they had to maneuver
the cameras and crew
into a position where they wouldn't be
seen it was the first scene of the
entire film to be shot but that didn't
stop the actors from bonding while the
fight was coordinated
part of what you see in the film was
actually rob and cam gigande improvising
you're beautiful the visual effects lead
called adding the vampire sparkle the
biggest challenge they faced while
making the film because they needed to
make edward look
smooth at the same time they did this by
mapping out robert
and adding sparkles in during editing
but robert and kristen still needed to
film the actual scene where he reveals
himself
it may look like a simple take of them
relaxing in the meadow but in reality
the two actors were under a very bright
light to mimic the sun that was blinding
you can see them struggling to keep
their eyes open and their giggles of
relief when they call
cut cat good good huh
the outdoor prom scene was a nightmare
to film not only was it at 2 am but it
was only 22 degrees outside and the cast
and crew were freezing
especially kristen who had to get
through the take in nothing but a little
sweater
the temperature also caused slippery
conditions and a wipeout from rob that
kristen still regrets not being there to
witness
rob fell no i didn't see rob fall i wish
i did
a lot was taken into consideration when
it came to the soundtrack of the film
catherine had to make sure that the
music also played into the emotional
aspect of the story and was there for
the entire process
rob even has two original songs that
made it onto the soundtrack of the first
film the songs were titled never think
and let me sign and the song edward
walks into the cafeteria to was sung by
his sister
could you act human i mean i've got
neighbors from the start
rob and kristen hit it off so much that
rob was warned not to date kristen off
screen because she was underage
however before that catherine needed to
test out their chemistry
in her bedroom the two acted out the
couple's first kiss at catherine's house
and it was rob's one chance to impress
looks like he did he then went into
major prep mode working out five days a
week and
even getting his driver's license but he
ran into some trouble creatively when
filming and was almost fired
they flew up and they're like yeah you
gotta you have to do the opposite of
what you're doing now you're gonna get
fired today
luckily it all worked out both off and
on screen
i am here to do my my big cameo this is
my break into the movie industry
it's a well-known fact that stephanie
meyer made an appearance at the diner
where bella and charlie have dinner one
night
but have you ever wondered what she was
doing on her laptop meyer was actually
writing breaking dawn while this scene
was being filmed
she had to make sure that they didn't
catch anything that was on her laptop in
fear that fans would become
super sleuths and zoom in on her screen
it wasn't all vegetarian sparkly
vampires on set
things got dark especially for nikki
reed rosalie's platinum blonde hair
posed a huge issue and was quite the
nightmare for the actress
my hair fell out it took 36 hours
initially to make me blonde
and every other day i was bleaching my
head and my skin
yikes yeah let's just keep pretending
like this isn't dangerous for all of us
the twilight saga really did start from
the bottom with an extremely small
budget
new on-the-scene actors and a lot of
hope catherine hardwick and the cast
turned the film into one the world will
never forget
what behind the scenes moment is your
favorite thanks for watching